♪ ♪
FEEL LIKE CRIME IN THE COUNTRY
IS A BIG ISSUE?
>> YEAH, FOR SURE IT'S CREATING
CRAZIER IT SEEMS.
>> I THINK CRIME IS AN ISSUE
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
IT SEEM LIKE IT IS GETTING
WORSE.
I GUESS BY THE WEEKS.
>> I'VE ALWAYS BEEN CAREFUL A
WOMAN LIVING IN A CITY SOLO SO
IF I'M WALKING AT NIGHT I MAKE
SURE I HAVE A BUDDY WITH ME.
I SPEND A LOT ON ÜBERS BUT
THAT'S HOW LIFE HAS TO BE.
>> GUNS RIGHT NOW PROBABLY
CRIME.
>> I WOULD SAY YEAH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE GETTING SHOT
AROUND HERE.
LAWRENCE: SAFETY IS ON THE
BALLOT CROSS COUNTRY WE'RE THREE
DAYS OUT FROM ELECTION DAY AND
CRIME CRISIS AT THE TOP AND
PUBLIC IS A FOOTBALL.
VIOLENCE BLEATING FROM ONE CITY
AND SUBURBS AND BEYOND WE ONCE
DEMANDEDDIBILITYIBILITY AND
JUSTICE NOW THERE'S A
REREVOLVING DOOR FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS POLICE ARE WITH DENIAL
AND FINGER POINTING.
BUT REGARDLESS OF POLITICS,
LIVES ARE BEING FOREVER CHAINED
CUT SHORT BY LAWS ON THEIR SIDE.
WHEN YOU CAST YOUR VOTE ON
TUESDAY YOU MAY WANT